We were talking last time about,
uh, profits of the Syrian crisis.
We focused on,
we've seen,
we've talked about two of the
northern profits almost in Hosea.
And we started talking about
Isaiah who was a southern Prophet,
a prophet in Judah.
And we'll be talking now about the second
southern profit of the Assyrian crisis.
And that is Miko Amica. And he said
to come from the town of more Russia,
which is about 25 miles
southwest of Jerusalem.
So he's in Judah and he's the last
of the eighth century profits.
He's quite different from
the city bread Isaiah.
He seems to been a rural,
a prophet who spoke for the poor farmers.
Now he's prophesying in the
second part of the eighth century.
So seven 40 to about 700.
He's attacking the s the northern kingdom,
although he's a southern profit,
he attacks Israel for,
um,
idolatries and says that the kingdom
will surely fall because of these.
So he also follows the other
profits as we've seen in,
in condemning the people for their
moral failings, the greedy land owners,
a dishonest merchants,
the aristocracy.
They are all targets of his denunciations
as our other leaders, the priests,
the judges, a royalty, the royal
house, as well as other false profits.
But the greatest contrast
between Isaiah and Micah.
So if you want to differentiate these
two southern profits of the Assyrian
crisis in your mind,
the greatest contrast lies in his view
of the city as inherently corrupt.
It's inherently sinful.
It's inherently doomed to destruction.
Isaiah had preached the inviolability
of Xeon and Micah is sharply critical of
the Davidic Dynasty.
He ridiculed the idea of the
invite inviolability of xenon.
He ridicules the belief that the presence
of the sanctuary in Jerusalem somehow
protects the city from harm.
He says on the contrary,
that God will destroy his
city and his house if need be.
Micah three verses nine through 12 here,
this you rulers of the House of Jacob,
you chiefs of the house of Israel who
detest justice and make crooked all that
is straight who build Zion with crime,
Jerusalem with iniquity,
her rulers judge for gifts,
her priest give rulings for a fee
and her profits divine for pay.
And yet they rely upon the Lord
saying the Lord is in our midst.
No calamity shall overtake us assuredly
because of use ion shall be plowed as a
field. And Jerusalem shall become
heaps of ruins. And the Temple Mount,
a shrine in the woods. Stark contrast
then between site between Isaiah who,
who trusts and has confidence that God
will never allow his holy city to be
destroyed.
His sanctuary to be destroyed.
His presence in the midst of the city
is guarantee that it will survive.
And Micah says it's no
guarantee of anything.
One of the most famous passages in
the book of Micah is in chapter six,
eight verses in chapter six.
And this is a passage that takes
the form of a covenant lawsuit,
which we've talked about
before, the Reeve. Um, and
the structure is as follows.
I've put it up on the whiteboard there.
The first two verses are the issuing of
the summons, the summons to the case.
So the profit here is acting as God's
attorney and he summons the accused.
Any summons,
the witnesses,
those would be the mountains who
are to hear the case against Israel.
God's case against Israel.
Hear what the Lord is saying,
come present my case before the
mountains and let the hills here,
you pleading here you mountains.
The case of the Lord,
you from foundations of the
earth for the Lord has a case,
a lawsuit against his people.
He has a suit against Israel.
So those are the opening verses
and in verses three to five,
we then move on to the plaintiffs
charge God's charge or accusation.
And this is given again
through the attorney.
He appeals to Israel's memory of,
of all of the events that have
manifested his great love for her.
That begins with the exodus of course,
and continues with the entry into
the promise land. And he says,
Israel seems to have forgotten all of
these deeds that God has performed on her
behalf and the obligations that
those deeds obviously entail.
Israel's conduct in response to this
continuous benevolence on God's part is
appalling. In verses six to seven
you have the defendant's plea.
This is Israel, I'm speaking,
but Israel really of course,
has no case to plead and Israel knows
that I'm her only choice is to try to
affect reconciliation,
but she doesn't know where to begin.
Versus six to seven with what
shall I approached the Lord,
do homage to God on high shall I
approached him with burnt offerings with
calves, a year old? Would the Lord
be pleased with thousands of rams,
with myriads of streams of oil? Shall I
give my first born for my transgression,
the fruit of my body for my sin
and the prophetic attorney, right?
Because the profit is here acting as
the attorney in verse eight responds to
this. He has told you, Oh man,
what is good and what the Lord requires
of you only to do justice and to love
goodness and to walk humbly with your God.
And the word that has been translated
here, as goodness is this word has said,
this is the word that we discussed
last time in relation to Hosea.
And it's a word that seems to
refer to that covenantal loyalty,
that the loyal love of
covenantal partners.
And this is a classic passage that
really typifies the prophetic emphasis on
morality or the primacy of
morality and prophetic thought.
The book of Micah itself structurally
alternates three prophecies of doom with
three prophecies of restoration
or hopes it's doom restoration,
doing restoration, dune
restoration. These,
these last prophecies tell of the
Glory of Zion to come in the future.
These restoration passages may seem a
little out of keeping her out of step with
the scathing denunciations
are condemnations of Judah
in the other parts of
Micah's prophecy.
And so some scholars have suggested that
those restoration passages and those
references to God's unconditional promise
to preserve the Davidic kingdom and
the optimistic predictions
of universal peace. Um,
these must be interpretations
by later editor.
And it's true that certain
parts we see again in Isaiah,
but this is always a very difficult
case or issue because we know that the
prophetic writings do fluctuate wildly
between denunciation and constellation.
So I think that a shift in theme alone
is not ever a certain basis for assuming
interpolation,
outright contradiction perhaps.
But a shift in theme or tone is,
is never a solid basis for
assuming interpolation.
Anachronism is a very good
guide to interpretation.
So Micah explicitly refers to
the Babylonian exile, of course,
and that's going to be in five 86
and he's in the eighth century. Um,
he's also going to refer to the
rebuilding of the walls of Jerusalem.
The walls of Jerusalem aren't even
destroyed until five 86 for anyone to even
speak about rebuilding them.
So those little units or passages
may of course represent late,
late editorial interpretations,
but in its present form.
And that, that nice structure
of alternation, of, of
denunciation, restoration,
denunciation, restoration of
pattern, that happens three times.
And that structure is,
I think,
typical of the common paradox that we
find in the prophetic writings where they
try to balance God's stern judgment.
On the one hand is punishment with
his merciful love and salvation of his
people.
A further paradox lies in the very
preservation of prophecies like Mike is
Prophecy, prophecy. Um,
these prophecies were probably preserved
by priests in the temple even though
priests were very often among the targets
of the profits in their denunciations,
particularly mica.
All right,
so we've talked about the profits who've
responded to the Assyrian crisis right
towards the end of the eighth century
to in the north too, in the south.
Jerusalem survived the siege of seven
Oh one when the Assyrians laid siege,
I'm in 701 and that gave credence to
the royal ideology and the idea that God
was with Zion was with Jerusalem and
was with the house of David and would
preserve them. But even so, Judah
moves into the next century,
into the six hundreds in a considerably
weakened state after the siege. Um,
and it's during that century,
the first half of the next century that
is Syria reached the zenith of its of
its power in Judah.
You have king Monash,
it raining that King Manasseh
rain for nearly 50 years.
We're not sure of exact dates,
but somewhere around the six nineties
to the six forties, about six 40,
50 years now,
remarkably,
the Deuteronomistic historian devotes
only 18 verses to this king who reigned
for 50 years. And all of those
verses are entirely negative. Uh,
and that's in great contrast to their
treatment of his father has a Kia and his
grandson who follows him, um, Josiah, uh,
Menasha was apparently a loyal
vassal of Assyria. And it,
according to the biblical writer,
he reversed the reforms of his father
has a Kaia who is said by the writer to
have, um, you know, destroyed
idolatry and so on. Um, but he said,
who have reversed that and to have
adopted a Syrian norms as we move through
this century and move towards the
latter half of this century is Syria,
which is overextended itself,
is beginning to decline.
And some of the other states in the
ancient near east are able to break away
from Egypt, breaks away,
Babylon breaks away.
Josiah comes to the throne in Judah in
seven 40 he sees a serious weakness.
He decides to take advantage of that and
asserts Judean independence carries out
a series of reforms we've talked about
several times in six 22 which include
purging the cult,
perhaps of a Syrian religious influences,
centralizing worship of Yahweh
only and in Jerusalem and so on.
So this centralization of the cult served
probably a political political agenda
as well of asserting
independence from a Syria.
Syria is continuing to decline
towards the end of this century.
And in six 12 the capital
Nineveh will fall.
The Babylonians managed to conquer these
Syrians. And by destroying Nineveh,
it's actually an alliance
of meads and Babylonians.
So things are going quite well.
Josiah is king, he's a favored king.
But just a few years later,
he will die in a battle
against the Egyptians at Mcgee.
So just a little bit of
historical background for
you as we talk about the next
profits. Alright. So Josiah,
the king who's highly favored
will die in six oh nine.
Now Zephaniah was a Judean Prophet who
prophesied during the reign of King
Josiah. So we're going to be moving
on now to Zephaniah and Jeremiah as,
as the Babylonian, uh, profits
of the Babylonian crisis.
So we're going to throw in a couple
of prophetic characters along the way,
but there'll be the two main
profits of the Babylonian crisis.
Obviously in the south. All we have,
and I was a southern kingdom, Judah, um,
but I'll be picking up on two
other profits in a moment as well.
So he prophesied during the
time of King Josiah. Um,
some of his prophecies seem to date to
the time we think before Josiah's reforms
in six 22. And those prophecies tend
to be very pessimistic and very grim.
Judah is condemned. It's
condemned for apostasy, it's
condemned for decadence. Um,
all of the things that that
flourished under King Manasseh,
God is wrathful and his,
his wrath is imminent.
There will be a universal destruction
according to Stefania. All life hand,
animal and human will be exterminated.
So as we saw in the book
of Amos This Day of Yahweh,
way this day of the Lord,
which has been so eagerly awaited,
will not in fact be a day of triumph,
but a day of dark destruction and despair.
Zephaniah one 15 to 18 that
day shall be a day of Wrath,
a day of trouble and distress,
a day of calamity and desolation.
A day of darkness and deep gloom.
A day of densest clouds,
a day of horn blasts send alarms against
the fortified towns in the lofty corner
towers.
I will bring distress on the people and
they shall walk like blind men because
they sinned against the Lord.
Their blood shall be spilled like dust
and their fat like Dung. Moreover,
they're silver and gold shall not avail
to save them on the day of the Lord's
wrath and the fire of his passion,
the whole land shall be consumed for
he will make a terrible end of all who
dwell in the land can see why people
didn't enjoy listening to these profits.
Um, but at the same time, like the other
profits, Zephaniah also offered hope.
There will be a humble remnant which
will seek refuge in God. Um, these will,
these, these, um, Jewish exiles, uh,
he says will be delivered from their
oppressors and even gentiles will join in
the worship of God.
Zephaniah three verses 11 to 13.
In that day,
you will no longer be shamed for all
the deeds by which you have defied me.
For then I will remove the
proud and exalted within
you and you will be haughty.
No more on my sacred mount, but I will
leave within you a poor, humble folk.
So this idea of purging
the dross and leaving the,
the pure remnant and they shall
find refuge in the name of the Lord.
The remnant of Israel shall do
no wrong and speak no false hood.
A deceitful tongue shall not be in their
mouths only such as these shall graze
and lie down with none to trouble them.
Uh,
there will also be an end
gathering of any exiled. Verse 20.
At that time I will gather you and at
that time I will bring you home for I will
make you renowned and famous
among all the peoples on earth.
When I restore your fortunes
before their very eyes.
There's one passage in particular that
seems extraordinarily a joyous, uh,
it seems to announce the salvation as,
as happening now is present.
And so a lot of scholars
think that this was, um, um,
Zephaniah his reaction to
Josiah and Josiah is reform,
which seemed to him to perhaps be the
very salvation for which the nation was
longing. Chapter three verses 14 and
15, shout for joy fairs ion cry aloud,
o Israel, rejoice and be glad with
all your heart fair. Jerusalem,
the Lord has a node. The judgment
against you, he has swept away your foes.
Israel is sovereign. The Lord is within
you. You need fear. Misfortune. No more.
So this, this sounds very much like a, um,
a reaction to these reforms
initiated by Josiah.
This is hailed as the very restoration
of God's presence in the community of
Judah, uh, that that was desired.
The judgment has been a node.
These terrible things I've been
prophesying will not happen.
Another short prophetic book we should
mention now is the book of [inaudible].
Um, it's very different from
the other prophetic books.
It doesn't really contain prophecies
and it doesn't really upgrade the people
for their failings, which are two things
that most of the other prophets do. Um,
the book of Nahum is a short little
book and it's really a three,
a series of three poems.
And these are the first one is an
acrostic poem and alphabetical poem.
Um, you know, lines beginning with
successive letters of the alphabet,
the Hebrew Alphabet,
and these poems rejoice over the
fall of Nineveh in in six 12,
um,
the capital of the cruel Assyrian Empire.
The Assyrians were actually quite
widely hated in the ancient near east.
They were noted for their exceptional
brutality there in humanity,
particularly in their
conquest and empire building.
They deported populations wholesale.
They were guilty of all sorts of
atrocities like mutilating their captives.
They would butcher women and children,
all sorts of horrendous deeds.
We have lots of testimony about this,
both in a Syrian sources,
but other ancient near eastern sources,
texts as well as artwork.
So not home in this poem
is celebrating the Avenger,
avenging and wrathful God who has finally
turned around to destroy this terrible
enemy of, of Israel. And indeed
the world according to knock him.
It's quite true that God had
used a Syria as his tool.
He had used a Syria to discipline
the Kingdom of Israel, right?
They did destroy Israel and to
discipline Judah for Judas sins.
But God is ultimately
the universal sovereign.
And so a serious savagery,
even if it was part of God's
disciplining of his children,
is a serious savagery is itself something
that must be punished. So for now,
come the fall of Nineveh is God's
vengeance upon a Syria for her barbaric in
humanity. And the book of Naca, uh,
has often been praised for its very vivid,
poetic style.
It describes these armed legions that
march against Nineveh and plundered.
It's treasures and some of
the most exciting archeology
that's been going on has
been the digging up of,
of Nineveh.
I think the dig has up obviously stopped
for reasons having to do with the
climate and that part of the world.
But, um, the, the findings of,
of Nineveh and the stacking
of Nineveh and how, you know,
shallow pits were dug and treasures
thrown into them and covered over by the
gates of the city as people were fleeing.
And many of these things,
when you read the description of Nineveh
and look at some of the archeological
data, it's, it's quite fascinating,
but on looks forward to a
happy era of freedom for Judah.
And he says in two verse 15 for never
again shall the wicked come against you.
Well, this isn't true. And in
fact, in a few years Josiah
is going to be killed. Um,
Judah's going to be made subject to Egypt
and in fact, Babylon by six Oh five,
um, Babylon manages to
extract, um, you know,
tribute from Judah as a, as a vassal. Um,
so in a way we have here really a glaring
error and it's important to note that
this error in not home, it wasn't
updated. It wasn't, um, uh,
repaired in order to protect
his prophetic reputation.
So we see this interesting tension. We
sometimes see a prophetic books, um,
being edited, revised, um,
having interpretations put into them
partly out of this conviction that their
words must be relevant and
continue to have some relevance.
And other times there seems to be good
evidence that prophetic oracles were
preserved rather faithfully.
But with the fall of Nineveh,
national confidence
was probably boosted a.
And then things quickly turned sour with
the death of Josiah and six oh nine,
which was a terrible shock.
You have Judah lying trapped as
it were between two great powers,
Egypt in the South West Babylon in
the north east and in six oh five,
as I said,
Babylon managed to defeat Egypt and
reduced Judah to the status of a tributary
vassal under the king you theme,
um,
King Jehoiakim rebels.
And in response,
the Babylonians laid siege to Jerusalem.
There will be two sieges of
Jerusalem by the Babylonians,
just as we've had two sieges
earlier to see just one in five 97,
one and five 87, both
under Nebuchadnezzar, he
lays siege to Jerusalem.
And five 97 it doesn't destroy Jerusalem.
He kills the,
the king takes the king's son into
captivity in Babylon and installs a puppet
king.
I'm still under the assumption that
things could be kept under control.
So the puppet King
Zedekiah is on the throne,
but he also decides to rebel and
Assert Judas independence against the
Babylonians.
So neighborhood Netzero returns,
and this is in five 87 and now
the city is in fact captured.
The sanctuary is completely destroyed
and the bulk of the population is exiled.
And this is what brings to end,
uh,
nearly 400 years of independent
of an independent Hebrew nation.
The book of Habakkuk Cook was written
during this period, sort of 602,
the destruction somewhere in those years.
That's the period in which the
Babylonians attack Jerusalem twice.
And Habakkuk is another
unusual prophetic book.
It doesn't contain prophecies so much
as it contains philosophical musings on
God's behavior.
And we're going to see this increasing.
Now as we move into the
next section of the Bible.
When we complete the prophetic section,
we'll be encountering writings of very
different genres and some of them do
contain these philosophical
musings on God's conduct.
Have a cook one and two are a kind of
poetic dialogue between the profit and
yeah way and the prophet complains
bitterly about God's inaction.
Verses two and three of the first chapter,
How long o Lord Shall I
cry out and you not listen.
Shall I shout to you
violence and you not save?
Why do you make me see iniquity?
Why do you look upon wrong rating
and violence are before me.
Strife continues and contention goes on
and skipping down to verses 13 and 14
you whose eyes are too pure to look upon
evil who cannot countenance wrongdoing,
why do you countenance treachery and
standby idle while the one in the wrong
devours the one on the right, you have
made mankind like the fish of the sea,
like creeping things that have no ruler.
So God responds to these charges by
saying that the Babylonians are the
instruments of his justice,
even though they ascribed there might
and their success to their gods rather
than to Yak way.
Now we've already seen in other books.
The idea that I'm a conquering nation is,
is serving as the instrument
of God's punishment,
but Habbakuk is a little bit unusual
because he doesn't couch this idea in the
larger argument that Judah deserves
this catastrophic punishment.
There's a great difference between Haba
Cook and the Deuteronomistic historian,
for example,
because Haba Cook doesn't assert that
the people are suffering for their sins.
Haba Cook is struggling with what appears
to him to be a basic lack of justice,
right? The Deuteronomistic a story and
wants to assert God's justice and whatever
suffering happens is justifiable.
A cook is resisting that idea.
We're going to see that resistance
really come to a climax next week when we
talk about the book of Job,
but Hypo Cook in one for struggles with
this decision fails and justice never
emerges for the villain hedges
in the just man. Therefore,
judgment emerges deformed.
It's not merely that the wicked and
the righteous suffer the same fate.
It's that the wicked really seemed
to fair better than the just,
and that reduces humankind to the level
of fish and creeping things for whom
sheer power and not morality
is the principal consideration.
And having made this charge Habbakuk
awaits God. God's answer in chapter two,
verses one to five, he says,
I will stand on my watch,
take up my station at the post and
wait to see what he will say to me,
what he will reply to my complaint.
The Lord answered me and said,
write the prophecy down and scribe it
clearly on tablets so that it can be read
easily. The righteous man is
rewarded with life for his fidelity.
How much less then shall
the defiant go unpunished?
Not a terribly deep answer.
The righteous simply have to have faith
that justice will prevail and this faith
has sis to stain them through the
trials that challenged that very idea.
We'll see a deeper answer to this
same problem in the book of job.
The third chapter then shifts gears.
So much so that once again,
scholars say it must be an
interpolation. Um, but again,
I would warn that dramatic shifts in tone
and theme or not that uncommon in the
prophetic books, and we'd have to be
careful. But in this third chapter,
God is described as a warrior.
God, uh, he thunders from the east.
He hurls his spear.
He seeks vengeance on Israel's oppressors.
It may be that this is some editors to
respond to Hubba cooks skepticism that
y'all way will bring justice and bring
it soon. That he's waiting. How long?
Why is this taking you so long?
Why are you not acting?
And this image of I'm an avenging warrior.
God answers Hubba cooks opening question.
How long will God stand by and watch while
the Babylonians rape and pillage? Uh,
but on the other hand, it's possible
that it's Habbakuk himself. And again,
the book exhibits that same paradoxical
tension we've seen through so many of
the prophetic books.
Specifically,
he holds out the paradoxical
view that God's injustice,
God's justice is slow in coming,
but the righteous must have complete
faith in its ultimate execution.
But he's raised the issue of
theodicy the problem of evil,
the problem of suffering.
Ultimately he sees the problems resolution
only in some vision of the future and
avenging God when justice will be done.
That is typical of some
texts that we will see later,
particularly apocalyptic literature,
which is going to emphasize
patient waiting for an end
time where there will be
a cataclysmic final acts that
will bring justice and judgment.
Now the prophet who lived at the time of
the final destruction of Judah and saw
the fall of Jerusalem at the hands of the
Babylonians in five 87 was the prophet
Jeremiah. Another one,
another long prophetic books.
We have our three long prophetic books.
Isaiah of the Assyrian crisis,
Jeremiah of the Babylonian crisis and
Ezekiel writing from exile in Babylon.
And Jeremiah was born of a priestly family
in a village near Jerusalem, Anatolia.
And he began prophesying
while he was still a boy.
Now he was a contemporary of King
Josiah. And, and so he saw the, uh,
the renaissance that briefly occurred
under his guidance, the sweeping reform,
the eradication of a Syrian influences
that had been welcomed by King Monash,
Shia, the renewal of the covenant. Uh,
all of these activities that are so
highly favored by the biblical writer.
And when Josiah died,
Jeremiah also lamented his passing
along with the rest of the nation.
Jeremiah witnessed the final
destruction and the exile. Um,
the book of Jeremiah is a collection
of very different types of material.
There's really no clear organization.
There's no clear chronological order,
not that kind of thing.
You've been just sort of sit down and
read from beginning to end and hope it
will make sense.
There are prophecies.
There are oracles and diatribes
against foreign nations.
There are stories by a graphical
narratives. There's some poetry, uh,
and at the very end,
a little brief historical appendix,
which really resembles second
kings chapter 24 and 25.
So the literary history of,
of the book itself is also quite complex
because there's a great variation in
our ancient witnesses.
The CEP to again,
which is the Greek translation
of the Bible, Third Century BCE,
Greek translation of the Bible is it's
Jeremiah is much shorter than the version
of Jeremiah. Uh, and it's
arranged differently internally.
The arrangement is different.
There are also significant differences
between the Hebrew texts that we have now
and some fragments of Jeremiah that had
been found among the Dead Sea Scrolls.
So this attests to the very open
ended nature of written compositions.
In antiquity, we find three main types
of material. However, in Jeremiah,
the poetic oracles that I'm
generally are attributed to Jeremiah.
Then biographical anecdotes
and narratives about him,
which are attributed to his menu Ansas
and assistant whose name I don't think I
put up your morale,
Ben and Ben,
simply meaning son of. So Barak,
the son of Nuria whose uh,
whose name comes up quite a bit in the
book of Jeremiah and he is a scribe who
assists Jeremiah and it's thought that
perhaps a biographical narrative sections
were composed by [inaudible] Maria.
And then we also have certain editorial
notes about Jeremiah Jeremiah that are
in the style of the Deuteronomistic
historian, Deuteronomistic editor,
Jeremiah in general,
it seems to have very close connections
with the language and the ideology of
Deuteronomy. So if we look quickly
at the structure of the book,
for the most part,
the first 25 chapters,
Jeremiah one through 25 contain an
introduction and an account of Jeremiah's
call,
but then also poetic,
Oracle's with some biographical snippets
thrown in there as well, not snippets,
narratives,
biographical narratives as well as poetic.
Oracle's 26 to 29.
We have stories of his, um,
encounters, I should say,
run ins with other profits and with
authority figures of various types.
Chapters 30 to 33 are oracles
of hope and consolation.
34 to 45 are more pros,
stories and these stories center around.
And after the time of
the final destruction,
then we have several chapters,
46 to 51 that contain
Oracle's against nations.
Some of these scholars think might be
from other writers. And then again,
as I say,
it concludes with this historical appendix
about the fall of Jerusalem that's
extracted from second kings.
Uh,
Jeremiah preached the inevitable doom
and destruction of the nation because of
its violation of the covenant, which
was a very charter for her existence.
And his descriptions were quite
vivid and quite terrifying.
He denounced Israel's leaders,
the professional profits in particular
with whom he has many, uh, encounters. Um,
the professional profits are liars. He
says, because they prophesied piece.
He has some negative
references to priests as well,
but he's especially critical of king
you Jolla Keem who's the son of Josiah.
He can be compared to mica because he
also attacked this idea of this popular
ideology of the Inviolability of Zion.
As long as injustice and
oppression are practiced in Judah,
the presence of the temple
is no guarantee of anything.
Judah will suffer the faith that she
deserves for failure to fulfill her
covenantal obligations.
So God tells Jeremiah to go stand at
the gate of the temple and speak these
words. And this is a passage that's
often referred to as the temple sermon.
It's from chapter seven, thus said,
the Lord of hosts, the God of Israel,
mend your ways and your actions.
And I will let you dwell in this place.
Don't put your trust in illusions
and say the temple of the Lord,
the Temple of the Lord, the Temple
of the Lord. Are these buildings? No.
If you really mend your
ways and your actions,
if you execute justice
between one man and another,
if you do not oppress the stranger,
the orphan and the widow,
you hear the language of Deuteronomy,
right?
Those three are always together
and Deuteronomy drawing
very heavily on the same
language. If you do not oppress the
stranger, the orphan and the widow,
if you do not shed the blood
of the innocent in this place,
if you do not follow other
gods to your own hurt,
then only will I let you dwell in this
place in the land that I gave your
father's for all time. See, you are
relying on illusions that are to no avail.
Will you steal and murder and commit
adultery and swear falsely again illusion
to the deck log, right? Those
four terms in the decalogue,
will you steal and murder
and commit adultery and swear
falsely and sacrificed a
ball and follow other gods whom you have
not experienced and then come and stand
before me in this house which
bears my name and say we are safe,
safe to do all these apart things.
Do you consider this house?
Which bears my name to be a
den of thieves? As for me,
I have been watching declares the Lord.
So he attacked this doctrine
of the inviolability of Zion,
and that would have been,
I kind of clastic to say the least,
but he pointed to history
as proof for his assertion.
He cites the example of
Shiloh as an example,
if you remember during the period of the
judges when the Ark of the covenant was
peripatetic and would
stay at different places,
but for some time it came to rest at
Shiloh with the priest, Eli and his sons.
And in that time the Philistines managed
to destroy the sanctuary and capture
the ark and carry it off
into Philistine territory.
So the presence of the Ark of the covenant
is no guarantee of anything and the
belief that God would not
allow his temple, his city,
his anointed ruler to be destroyed.
Jeremiah says is a deception.
It's an illusion.
He,
his political message resembles very
much the message of his predecessors.
He says that the nation's pathetic
attempts to resist the great powers and to
enter into alliances with
the one against the other.
These were all completely futile and to
dramatically illustrate the destruction
and the slavery that were inevitable.
He paraded around Jerusalem first in a
wooden yoke and then in an iron yoke.
He does this in chapters 27 and 28
this is a symbol of the slavery,
the yoke of the master that is to come
in chapter 27 verse six he claims that
God has power over all the earth and
has given the earth to Nebuchadnezzar of
Babylon. God's servant.
As you can imagine,
referring to the destroyer of the
nation as God's servant would have been
shocking,
not to say dangerous.
You can imagine parallels in our own
time where people would see the god most
commonly understood to be
the god of most Americans,
being the one who orchestrated
attacks against that,
so it would have that same kind of
feel and power to people and in several
passages, Jeremiah exhorts the king
to submit to the Babylonian forces.
This is acceptance of God's will, the
forces that are surrounding Jerusalem, um,
to ensure the preservation of his words,
which were not popular.
Jeremiah had his amendments,
this borough write down
everything that God spoke to him.
Chapter 36 gives us an
insight into this process.
It's kind of interesting
because, um, Jeremiah, Jeremiah,
Jeremiah's words are transcribed.
God specifically tells Jeremiah how,
how to do this. Get a scroll. He says,
and write upon it all the words that I
have spoken to you concerning Israel and
Judah and all the nations from the time
I first spoke to you in the days of
Josiah to this time.
Now it's the time of King Yo Jakeem.
And then in verse four we read.
So Jeremiah called Barak,
the son of Nuria and Barack wrote down
in the scroll at Jeremiah is dictation.
All the words which the
Lord had spoken to him.
Now Jeremiah is in hiding at this time
because he's politically very unpopular.
So he instructs Barack to take the scroll
to the temple and to stand there and
to read it to the people.
The king's officials are there.
They report to the king about the
submersive, the subversive message,
which has been delivered by Barbara.
So brook goes into hiding,
the scroll is torn into strips and
burned God orders Jeremiah to get another
scroll and repeat the process.
And he does verse 32 of Chapter 36.
So Jeremiah got another scroll and gave
it to the scribe by real son of Neriah.
And at Jeremiah is dictation.
He wrote in it the whole text of the
scroll that King you Jolla Keem of Judah
had burned and more of the like
was added. So, and then some right,
they got came back with even more.
So it's possible that these,
some scholars suggest
that what was written, um,
would have been the contents
of chapters one to 25,
which really contains the
irregular material, the
oracles. Um, but in any event,
this story gives us some insight into
the profit. The process of prophecy.
It doesn't appear to have
been really off the cuff.
The compositions of the profits were
literary compositions that were committed
to memory. They could then be dictated
again. And on an archeological note,
I should point out that one of the most
exciting fines I think, um, is a claim.
In 1975,
they found a clay bula,
which is like a clay imprint of,
um,
baroque son of Nuria. The scribe is
what it says on the clay imprint.
Another one was found in 1996 it was
said to be found in a burnt house in
Jerusalem, which would've been
around the time of the destruction.
And it just showed up on the
antiquities market. So some question,
whether it's genuine or not,
the second one that was found has a
fingerprint on it. And people say, well,
that could be the fingerprint of
[inaudible], son of Neriah. Anyway,
this is the fun stuff you get
to do if you do archeology.
But there are plenty of people who think
that these probably are the seals of
the scribe, but Roxanne of an area that
he would've used to stamp anything, uh,
that he would have a
transcribed or written.
So Jeremiah was rejected.
He was despised.
He was persecuted by fellow Judeans.
Naturally,
they would have seen him as a trader.
Um, he was flogged. He was imprisoned,
uh, often in his life. He was in hiding.
He was a very troubled person and he
lived in very difficult times. But he,
we also get an insight into his,
his emotional state,
which we don't for many of the other
prophets. He suffered immensely.
He weeps over Jerusalem.
In chapter eight a and nine,
we get a sense of the
turmoil that he suffers,
particularly because of a group of
passages that are referred to as the
confessions of Jeremiah. And these
are sort of scattered throughout, um,
some in chapters 11
and 12, 15, 17, 18, 20.
But these are passages
that reveal his interstate.
Some people question their authenticity,
but in any event,
they paint a very fascinating
portrait of the Prophet.
He curses the day that he was born.
He accuses God of deceiving him,
of enticing him to act as God's messenger,
only to be met with humiliation and shame.
But he can't hold it in God's words,
rage inside him. And he must prophesied.
It would be better had he not been born
at all than to suffer this ceaseless
pain. Chapter 20 verses seven through
18 just selections from there,
you enticed me,
Oh lord and I was enticed.
You overpowered me and you prevailed.
I have become a constant laughingstock.
Everyone jeers at me for every
time I speak, I must cry out.
I must shout lawlessness and ray pine
for the word of the Lord causes me
constant disgrace and contempt. I thought
I will not mention him no more. Well,
I speak in his name, but his word was
like a raging fire in my heart. Shut up,
shut up in my bones. I could
not hold it in. I was helpless.
I heard the whispers of the crowd
terror all around, informed.
Let us inform against him. A curse would
be the day that I was born a curse.
It'd be the man who brought
my father the news and said,
a boy is born to you
and gave him such joy.
Let that man become like the cities
which the Lord over through without
relenting because he did
not kill me before birth.
So that my mother might be my grave
and her womb big with me for all time.
Why did I ever issue from the womb to see
misery and woe to spend all my days in
shame?
Nevertheless,
despite all of his very
harsh criticisms of,
of the establishment authorities
or royal house and even scribes,
other profits who are
labeled as liars by Jeremiah,
his words were preserved by scribes,
by the Deuteronomistic editors.
Shortly after the fall of Judah,
Jeremiah was taken forcibly to Egypt and
he lived his final years out in Egypt.
He didn't give up his job, though he kept
announcing people. He, um, we have, uh,
records of his denouncing his fellow
Judean exiles down in Egypt, uh,
for worshiping the Queen of Heaven.
And as before it seems
very few heated him there,
but like the earlier prophets,
Jeremiah also balanced his message
with a message of constellation.
And there's some very interesting and
unique features of Jeremiah's message of
consolation.
These are particularly these passages or
found particularly in chapters 30 to 33
where we have more
hopeful, um, prophecies.
He envisages a restoration.
The exile will come to an end.
And in fact,
Jeremiah is the first to actually set a
time limit to what we might refer to as
the dominion of the idolaters and
idolaters holding sway over God's people.
And that time limit,
and he says is 70 years.
Jeremiah writes a letter to
the first group of deportees.
So remember the first siege and five
97 you have the king killed his son and
many people taken into exile in Babylon.
Jeremiah from Jerusalem writes a letter
to that first group of exiles and it's
quite remarkable.
It's found in chapter 29 and it's
quite remarkable for its council.
It's advice to the exiles to settle down
and their adopted home and just wait
out.
The time there is an appointed end,
he warns the people not to listen to
prophets who say you will return shortly.
It's just a lie.
The Israelites have to serve the king of
Babylon and by doing so, they will live.
So in Jeremiah 29 versus four to seven,
thus said,
the Lord of hosts, the God of
Israel, to the whole community,
which I exiled from Jerusalem to Babylon.
Nice. He's writing to the exiles,
build houses and live in them.
Plant gardens and eat their fruit.
Take wives and beget sons and daughters
and take wives for your sons and give
your daughters to husbands that they may
bear sons and daughters. Multiply there.
Do not decrease and seek the welfare of
the city to which I have exiled you said
of seek the welfare of Jerusalem.
Seek the welfare of the city to which I
have exiled you and pray to the Lord and
its behalf for in its prosperity,
you shall prosper.
In other words,
you're in for the long
haul and you shouldn't be
deceived by the idle dreams or
the false prophets, uh, who tell
you that return is imminent.
God has other plans. They are
plants for welfare, not for evil.
And they will give you a future
and a hope. At the end of 70 years,
Jeremiah said there will be a great war
of all the nations and Judah and Israel
will be returned to their land.
Xi'An he declared would be acknowledged
as the holy city and a new Davidic king
would rein new covenant would
be made with Israel as well.
And this time Jeremiah says
it's a covenant that will
be etched on the heart in
coded as it were into human nature.
Jeremiah 31 verses 31 to 34 see,
a time is coming declares the Lord.
When I will make a new covenant with the
House of Israel and the House of Judah,
it will not be like the Covenant I made
with their fathers when I took them by
the hand to lead them out of the land
of Egypt to covenant which they broke so
that I rejected them,
declares the Lord,
but such as the covenant I will make
with the house of Israel after these days
declares the Lord.
I will put my teaching into their inmost
being and inscribe it upon their hearts
and then I will be their God
and they shall be my people.
And no longer will they need to teach
one another and say to one another,
he'd the Lord for all of them,
from the least of them to the greatest
shall he'd me, declares the Lord.
So this is a remarkable idea.
It seems to express some,
some dissatisfaction with
the element of free will,
which is otherwise so crucial to the
biblical notion of Covenant and Morality.
The idea that humans freely
choose their actions. After all,
when you think about some of the major
themes set out in the Hebrew Bible at the
very beginning and the opening
chapters, um, this would seem to be, uh,
a cardinal principle choice,
but free choice does mean of course
that there will be bad choices and there
will be disobedience and evil
and people can get tired of that.
And Jeremiah was so,
his utopian ideal is inspiring,
but it does eliminate
the element of free will.
It seems to describe a situation in
which humans are almost hardwired to obey
God's covenant.
And that's attention that will also
be developed in some later texts.
I just note it here in a
very beautiful passage.
Jeremiah describes a future
restoration of the temple,
the bringing up offerings. Again,
the singing of psalms and praise.
And this is in contrast to chapter 25
they're in chapter 25 he warned that God
will banish the sound of mirth
and gladness, the voice of bride,
groom and bride leaving
the land desolate ruin.
And now in his article of
Constellation, Jeremiah says, and again,
there shall be heard in this place in
the towns of Judah and the streets of
Jerusalem that are desolate without
men, without inhabitants, without beast,
the sound of Mirth and gladness,
the voice of bridegroom and bride,
the voice of those who cry give
thanks to the Lord of hosts,
for the Lord is good for his kindness,
his everlasting,
as they bring Thanksgiving
offerings to the house of the Lord,
for I will restore the fortunes of
the land as of old, said the Lord.
So just to kind of summarize these,
these profits leading up to the time
of the destruction, because next,
next time we'll be talking about
the exile and and later the return.
But the fall of Jerusalem
shattered the national and,
and territorial basis of
Israel's culture and religion.
The had burned the temple to the ground.
They carried away most of the people
to exile, to live in exile in Babylon,
leaving behind mostly members of of the
lower classes to eke out a living, um,
as best they could.
And it was the completion of a tragedy
that had begun centuries earlier and it
was interpreted as a fulfillment
of the covenant curses.
It was the end of the Davidic monarchy,
although the Deuteronomistic historian
does close with this note that the son of
your holy Jakeem was alive
and living in Babylon,
kind of holding out hope that the
line had actually been killed out. Um,
I haven't, uh, been completely wiped out,
but the institutions seemed to
have come to an end for now. Um,
it was the end of the temple,
the end of the priesthood,
the end of Israel as a nation
is that an autonomous nation.
And so the Israelites were confronted
with a great test as I've stressed before.
One option would be to see in these
events a signal that Yahweh had abandoned
them to or had been defeated by the
god of the Babylonians and Marduk would
replace Yaffe way as the
Israelites assimilated
themselves into their new home,
and certainly there were
Israelites who went this route,
but others who were firmly rooted
and exclusive. Yeah, wisdom did not,
and they're the ones who left us there.
Literature.
How could this faith survive outside
the framework of Israelite National
Culture, away from the temple and
the land uprooted and scattered?
Could Israelite religion survive
without these national foundations and
institutions and on foreign soil or
would it go the way of other national
religions?
You hear the pain and the despair that
would have been experienced at this time.
In the words of the Psalmist,
Psalm one 37 which is written at
this time by the rivers of Babylon.
There we sat,
sat and wept as we thought
of Zion there on the poplars,
we hung up our liars for our captors.
Ask us there for songs,
our tormentors for amusement.
Sing us one of the songs of Zion.
How can we sing a song of the Lord on
Alien Soil? If I forget you o Jerusalem,
let my right hand,
whether that my tongue stick to my palate,
if I cease to think of you,
if I do not keep Jerusalem in memory,
even at my happiest hour.
And it was the message of the profits
that helped some Israelites make sense of
their situation in a manner that kept
them distinct and invulnerable to
assimilation.
And this was probably the reason for the
preservation of the prophetic writings,
even though they had often been despised
or an unheated in their own lifetimes.
Yeah, why hadn't been defeated? They
claimed the nation's calamities.
We're not disproof of his power and
covenant. They were proof of it.
The prophets had spoken truly when they
had said that destruction would follow
if the people didn't turn from their moral
and religious violations of God's law.
So that rather than
undermining faith in God,
the defeat and the exile when interpreted
in the prophetic manner had the
potential to convince Jews of the need
to show absolute and undivided devotion
to God and his commandments.
So that paradoxically,
the moment of greatest national despair
could be transformed by the profits into
an occasion for it.
The renewal of religious faith,
the great contribution of the profits
was their emphasis on God's desire for
morality as expressed in
the ancient covenant there.
The great contribution of Jeremiah was
his insistence on God's everlasting
covenant with his people,
even outside the land of Israel.
And despite the loss of national religious
symbols, the temple, the holy city,
the Davidic King,
and this insistence that the faithful
person's relationship with God wasn't
broken even in an idolatrous land when
added to Jeremiah as notion of a new
covenant,
provided the exiles with the ideas that
would transform the nation of Israel
into the religion of Judaism.
And next time we're going to turn to to
post destruction profits who also helped
the nation formulate a viable response
to the tragedy that had befallen them.
This is a point at which we can
begin to use words like Judaism.